- It's nice to see you again.
- Nice to see you.
- The last time I saw you,
you didn't have a kid.
You have a two year old now.
- And you didn't have an Emmy.
- Well, boom.
(audience clapping)
- Well and a baby.
(Kelly laughing)
I mean, that's not doing too bad.
- We're killing it.
That's how is it, two, right?
Two years old.
- She's two years old.
I was pretty much pregnant
during the whole pandemic.
- Wow.
- Great way to keep it a secret
'cause all your meetings
are from here up, you know.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, that's awesome.
- Yeah.
And I had a daughter.
Yeah, in August of 2020.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, it was the best.
- [Kelly] I'm very happy for you.
I have kiddos and there's
six and eight now,
but that's magical.
Every step is challenging but
every step is magical as well.
But being,
being a first time parent
can be hard though.
So who's your go-to for advice?
- I mean, I have a
couple little mom groups.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Mom friends and then
my own mom, of course.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I hope so as well.
You went through a challenging time
with your mama, right?
- Yeah.
- I mean, I feel like I could have asked
any of us that question.
(audience laughing)
- I know, right?
- I feel like we all even are
mothers with their mothers.
Yeah.
- The relationship is such a journey
and that's what's beautiful about it.
But you know, it's one
of the things I write
about in my book that
I was really ashamed of
and embarrassed for a long time is that,
I was, like estranged
from my mother for like
five, six years.
Didn't speak to her.
- Wow.
- Not even in email.
And that's on me.
And the beautiful thing
about becoming pregnant was,
it sort of brought us together again
and we've reconciled since then.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, you know, continue
building a wonderful relationship.
- Yeah. It gives you a fresh
perspective on parenting too.
- Oh, 100%.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause my mom had four.
- And I only have one
and I'm like, how do you?
- Yeah, my mom had three
and I two and I'm just like, whoa.
You're outnumbered.